penelope cruz keeps it equal parts
glamorous classic and timeless on the
red carpet
one of her best red carpet moments of
all time came in 2007 the first time
oscar nominee wore a pale pink versace
with a feathered train that left fans
spawning a year later she wowed us again
with a black chanel gown the first of
many for penelope who's now been a
longtime ambassador for chanel and face
of the brand and who can forget 2009
when she took home her first win yep all
eyes run penelope her new oscar and of
course the white vintage beaumont and
while penelope cruz isn't someone who
shies away from color on the red carpet
one of our favorite fashion moments came
in 2020 when she stunned in a classic
black and white yup you guessed it
when it comes to 2022 predictions like
we said penelope cruz is a chanel girl
although she rocked it in red the last
time she was up for an oscar we think
this time around we can expect something
a little bit more classic
we'd also love to see her in a carolina
herrera if she wanted to switch things
up with a pop of color
whatever penelope rocks on the red
carpet if it's anything like years past
the spanish star is sure to be one of
the nice best dressed